DJ is with us in Sacramento hi DJ how
are you I'm doing alright how about
yourself
better than I deserve sir how can I help
so my father passed away and I believe
it was me and he left us with this house
and I'm currently 20 years old and in
order for us to sell the house we have
to get the property cleaned up and and
ready for sales but there was some
squatters there since no one lived there
and it's a mess and it's going to take a
lot of time to clean it up and I
unfortunately cannot do that and my
question was is it's all right to use my
credit cards to have someone do that in
order to sell it and I'll make a profit
off the property and then I could pay my
cards off if it all works perfect it
works perfect that's how dead always is
but if it doesn't work out that way
then you end up with credit card debt
and a house that hasn't sold that's and
then you want to turn it into a rental
and then you got the credit card debt
and all the things that can go wrong do
go wrong so let's talk about this a
minute where is the house the house is
in a Calaveras County
which is way out in the middle of
nowhere okay and what is the house worth
the market says that the property and
the house itself is worth two hundred
thousand to two hundred twenty thousand
really and and so it's just full of
trash and stuff yeah my dad was an auto
mechanic and he had a lot of cars and
things there but when he passed away no
one was able to stay on the property so
are you a the only heir I'm the only one
old enough how many errors are there
there's me and then there's my younger
brother who is 17 that you're gonna
split this money with yes okay and was
there a will there was not a will okay
have you probated this you need to
contact an attorney and talk to them
about what you've got to do in the state
of California to get this house into
your name okay the house is in my
grandmother's name and she is still
alive
okay so your grandmother owns the house
yes she wants it
toward for clothes at this point and I
would really hate this here do that oh
wait a minute what's owed on the house
seventy thousand and it's worth two
hundred yeah and if I if so who's gonna
get the money when it sells it would go
to myself and my brother why it's in
your grandmother's name because my
grandmother doesn't want any of it she
understands that it was my father's
house and property even though I first
signed it off ever sign it over to you
sign it over to me yeah it's not yours
and when you get exalted cleaned up and
sold suddenly one of your cousins is
going to show up and go I want my share
this was Granny's house it wasn't your
dad's which would actually be legally
the truth okay because it's not your
dad's house it's not in his name right
that's what decides whose house it is
that's what the law says okay I
understand you got all this moral family
crap going on but none of that's the
truth the truth is what the law says on
this so having said all of that was your
dad a member of a church he was not is
your grandmother as well okay do you
have familiarity with a good Church in
the area of the house kind of close
another couple towns over like I said it
was in the middle of nowhere but yes
okay suggestion call the church and talk
to the youth pastor or find another
charity of some kind that has labor
available to it youth pastors have labor
they're called teenagers and tell them
you will give them one-third of the net
proceeds of the house if they'll go
clean it up that's a good idea I never
thought of that
and then the house is going to go on the
market and we're gonna agree to you let
them share we're gonna make a donation
to your youth group of whatever that
amounts to twenty thousand bucks or
something but you got to make this place
spick-and-span it's got to be so
unbelievably beautiful that it actually
sells because none of us are going to
get anything if it doesn't sell
that's sure and in the meantime get the
house deeded to you okay
or tell grandmother to deal with her
house because it's not your house it's
not your dad's house right now if the
house is supposed to be you and your
brothers indeed it to y'all and she can
do that with a simple quit claim deed
and it does not make you liable on the
mortgage and it does make you liable if
somebody gets hurt on the property so
get insurance but contact somebody and
agree to share it with them somehow if
they clean it up and you might just make
that deal with a local guy who likes to
clean up stuff I don't know but you
hadn't got time to go over there and do
it it sounds like it's a tangled up
family mess anyway and I don't blame you
for being a little bit hands-off on it
but there's no chance you should use
credit card debt to clean this up no
chance at all as a matter of fact there
is a real chance that as you get off the
phone right now you should get those
credit cards out of your wallet play
scissors across them and squeeze it's
time for Plus ectomy you shouldn't even
have those stupid things in the first
place and then this question wouldn't
come up thanks for calling